[Musique]
salut à tous soyez les bienvenus ses
services première votre émission d'info
service on est vous le constater en
plein coeur de foyal sous le kiosque
guide on a la mer on fasse on a vous
tous derrière qui passait en voiture
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui en plein coeur de fort de
france d'autant plus qu'on est avec une
invitée une réalisatrice julie hamiti
bonjour merci d'être venu aujourd'hui
nous parler de ce film documentaire à
yantai on va parler du mouvement
rastafari et on va également parler
d'écologie aujourd'hui dans services
pros bien on va voir le lien un petit
peu entre le mouvement rastafari et
l'écologie alors tout d'abord les rastas
on connaît ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on voit évoluer des rastas autour de
nous en martinique en plus on est bien
placé dans le bassin caribéen la
jamaïque terre du mouvement rastafari
même si ça n'a pas forcément pris
naissance qu'en jamaïque
d'après ce que j'ai compris alors oui on
peut dire que c'est un prix mais ça
brille ça c'est beaucoup exporté aussi
ailleurs tout à fait donc ça vient à la
base si on prend la naissance en
jamaïque
ça vient de marcus garvey qui était un
grand défenseur de la cause noire qui
qui a dit en 1927 regarder vers
l'afrique un roi noir va être couronnée
et la délivrance se rapproche et trois
ans après et les sélassié est couronné
empereur d'ethiopie et est donc
considéré comme que comme christenson 41
royal alors le but de cette émission de
cette agence va pas être de faire du
prosélytisme de dire soit et rasta c'est
de parler de ce mouvement rastafari de
le comprendre dans son évolution dans la
façon dont on le vit également ici dans
le bassin packard ibm et pas qu'en
caraïbes comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure même également en afrique
d'ailleurs ce travail sur le mouvement
rastafari est parti un petit peu de delà
d'une rencontre inattendue tout à fait
donc c'était lors d'un
d'un voyage en afrique il ya cinq ans
maintenant j'ai rencontré un jeune homme
sur la plage au sénégal on a parlé un
petit moment et au bout d'un moment il
me dit qu'ils les rastas et il avait
aucune locks il avait le crâne rasé il
était très sérieux étudiants et moins à
cette époque là j'avais encore beaucoup
de clichés en tête sur le sur le
mouvement rasta
donc j'ai pas du tout compris de quoi il
me parlait et et du coup il a commencé à
me parler de tout le côté retour aux
racines retour à l'afrique et de cette
fois on a laissé l'acier et j'ai trouvé
que c'était beaucoup plus profond que ce
que ce que je pensais
et qu'il fallait il fallait que je fasse
plus de recherche et que je fasse
découvrir au public ce que j'ai ce que
j'apprenais mais parce que nous à part
si on a quelqu'un un ami qui est
peut-être rasta on s'arrête au locks on
s'arrête au peut-être la nourriture a et
al des fois des voies plus le cannabis
et le raccourci un peu facile
donc on n'est pas profondément en fait
cette philosophie art déjà ce que c'est
une religion c'est une philosophie sa
mode de vie c'est quoi exactement moi je
dirais une philosophie de vie après
après je suis pas forcément la meilleure
personne pour en parler moi j'ai essayé
de donner la parole donc aux frères et
soeurs resta que j'ai rencontré et sur
mon chemin
mais gérer c'est une philosophie de vie
qui englobe une spiritualité plus qu'une
religion en tout cas ce qui est ce
qu'ils se sont ouverts justement en
voyant quelqu'un qui n'était pas en
reste à venir
vouloir faire un documentaire sur es que
ce qu'ils étaient assez ouverts à ça ou
un peu réticents alors on me demande
souvent si c'était facile alors je
dirais pas jusqu'à dire que c'était
facile
en fait le plus gros travail à mon avis
de réalisatrice de documentaires c'est
de réussir à expliquer pourquoi je suis
là et a créé un lien de confiance avec
les interviewés et donc c'est ça qui m'a
aussi beaucoup plus c'est que j'ai
réussi à créer donc ce lien et à faire
en sorte que les gens interviewés se
confie créé et c'est une relation qui
est très forte en fait allé voir les
gens pour leur demander en quoi vous
croyez pourquoi vous viviez comme ça ça
crée tout de suite un lien fort et donc
j'ai réussi à créer siens là avec
beaucoup de personnes il y en a d'autres
avec qui ça s'est moins bien passé mais
je pense que c'est les aléas du tournage
est-ce qu'en 2019
il est facile d'être rasta de vivre
selon un mode de vie rasta je sais qu'il
ya quelques années pas loin de chez nous
un dans des îles anglophones unilingues
anglophones en particulier de la
caraïbes la dominique pour ne pas la
citer il ya une très très grosse
répression qui était d'ailleurs très
violente vis-à-vis de la communauté
rasta c'était carrément interdit d'être
à stains oui alors je suis donc allé en
dominique tourner aussi pour parler de
cette loi qui est qu'on appelle le dre
d'actes qui autorisait donc à tirer à
vue sur les rastas voilà les gentils
avec des dreadlocks ou que même qui
portait les calebasses qui avait adopté
la vie la vie rasta sur certains clichés
comme ça mais juste à vue et donc il ya
on dit entre 21 et 30 trente et une
personnes qui ont été tuées à ce moment
là et la plupart enfermés neuf mois
directement en prison avec les locks
coupé énormément de violence dans les
cellules donc donc voilà c'est pas rien
si c'était qu'un style comme certains
pensent on ne serait pas arrivé là
donc c'est pas facile c'est sûr des
traces taille partout par contre il ya
peut-être un regain maintenant je sais
pas il il ya beaucoup de gens qui
portent des locks il ya beaucoup de gens
qui cherchent à manger mieux donc
peut-être que peut-être un petit peu
plus de gens qui s'intéressent au
mouvement rasta mais c'est encore très
compliqué surtout en afrique qui a
encore il ya très peu il ya quelques
mois il ya une village rasta en côte
d'ivoire où il ya eu un raid de police
et ils sont fait couper les locks il ya
eu extrêmement de violence il ya encore
des gens en afrique qui se font couper
les locks directement et est envoyé en
prison juste part des clichés donc ça
reste encore difficile dans certains
pays de vivre selon ce mode de vie un
mode de vie qui a beaucoup évolué chez
nous on s'intéresse maintenant à la
martinique où ça quand même beaucoup
évolué je me rappelle encore quelques
années les concerts reggae était
interdit dans certaines municipalités
c'était très très compliqué d'organiser
marley marathon par exemple aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup plus simple en tout cas
chez nous ça a l'air d'être beaucoup
plus simple les mentalités ont évolué
chez nous par rapport au mouvement
rastafari
alors je pense
comme on dit c'est toujours très
difficile parce que quand on le montre
quand on a des dreadlocks et quand on
essaye de vivre un mode de vie droit et
en dehors du système on a souvent des
bâtons dans les roues mais comme je
disais je pense que les gens
s'intéressent de plus en plus et tu vois
qu'il ya énormément de bon sens dans ce
mouvement et que c'est intéressant de
prendre exemple en fait et c'est un
petit peu pour ça moi que je me suis
motivé à faire ce film et à montrer ce
que j'avais découvert parce que moi en
faisant mes recherches
il ya énormément de principes de vie
auquel j'ai adhéré déjà et j'ai trouvé
une sorte de cohérence en fait dans ce
mouvement qui va à la fois prenez donc
une vie saine par la nourriture une
fille saine par le l'endroit où on vit
être en dehors de la société de
consommation à la fois une spiritualité
une recherche d'identité donc c'est
vraiment très complet et essayer de
garder une droiture dans tous ses
principes en parler d'écologie au début
de l'émission deux ex ce lien entre le
mouvement rastafari et l'écologie on
parle beaucoup d'écologie
ces derniers temps c'est c'est très
important on se rend compte qu'il faut
prendre soin de la planète même dans
notre alimentation avoir des
comportements beaucoup plus +1 beaucoup
plus logique beaucoup plus en rapport et
en respect de la nature ce sont là des
idées qu'ils ont tourné depuis des
années par un lancement en fait d'être
proche de la mère nature comme ils
disent
c'est ça donc là on est dans une période
où on essaye de revenir ressources
essayez de manger plus sainement et en
fait c'est ça fait des dizaines d'années
que les restes a promis ça donc essayer
de manger les légumes qu'on cultive
manger le moins de sel de sucre possible
de gras voilà essayer de préparer les
choses en prenant le temps avec amour et
ne pas aller dans des fast-foods manger
le plus rapidement possible
donc ça ce sont des choses que les
rastas prône depuis des dizaines
d'années et qu'on commence à écouter que
maintenant alors qu'on les a moqué très
longtemps les plantes également se
soigner par les plantes
oui alors vacances et quand c'est
possible bien évidemment on parle de
deux médecines douces on parle pas de
forcément bannir les le but n'est pas de
dire qu'il faut bannir les médicaments
mais en tout cas de pression donc
certaines petites choses qu'on peut
régler simplement bon mais ont beaucoup
de choses après il sait juste qu'il faut
prendre la décision si on a une maladie
grave de ne pas utiliser la médecine
occidentale c'est une décision très dure
à prendre mais à mon avis tout et
soignable par les plantes
c'est donc c'est la médecine qui est
utilisé depuis depuis la nuit des temps
et donc je sais ce que j'ai découvert
aussi en allant à la rencontre des
adeptes du mouvement rastafari et et
et donc voilà on a j'ai aussi entendu au
ghana par exemple le quand je suis
arrivée des gens qui se battaient contre
monsanto
donc pour moi c'est moi je fais partie
de toutes ces mouvements contre contre
monsanto
donc c'est vrai que je j'ai entendu à
chaque fois où j'allais des principes
que j'avais déjà d'écologie mais
vraiment profonde et appliquer un
reportage donc un documentaire très
intéressant qui s'appellerait maille qui
a déjà été vu dans plusieurs pays en
fait l'espagne je crois oui la france
aussi également beaucoup en martinique
il a déjà été aussi projetés oui alors
c'est pour ça que je suis en martinique
en ce moment j'ai fait un petit peu le
tour des îles je suis retourné en
dominique à sainte christie en
martinique je suis aussi allé en
guadeloupe pour le présenter donc l'idée
c'était une fois qu'ils étaient
terminées d'aller le montrer aux
personnes qui ont participé les
personnes qui ont été interviewés et
donc pour montrer le résultat de ce à
quoi ils ont participé et je suis très
contente de venir leur montrer ce que
j'ai ce que j'ai accompli
j'avais j'étais un petit peu anxieuse
d'avoir d'avoir alors le retour là
dessus et il est donc il a donc été
diffusée deux fois en martinique une
fois à saint pierre une fois à dillon et
le retour sont assez bons comment réagit
justement la communauté rasta par
rapport à ce documentaire plutôt bien
après c'est sûr qu'il ya tellement de
choses à dire la même moi j'ai fait donc
je suis parti dans différents pays
j'aurais pu en faire beaucoup plus
j'ai 60 heures de rushes à peu près à la
fin il reste plus qu'une heure de film
53 minutes même donc c'est sûr que c'est
très succinct moi j'essaye de présenter
en fait la philosophie rasta droit en
général
dans son ensemble et il ya beaucoup plus
de détails qui qu'on pourrait donner
j'ai mis dans le dvd des bonus pour pour
que les gens aillent voir un petit peu
plus loin mais c'est vrai que on me dit
j'aurais pu aussi montré d'autres choses
il manque peut être encore des choses
des choses à présenter mais j'espère que
ça donnait ça attise la curiosité du
public et que les gens iront après faire
leurs propres recherches
oui et puis ce sera peut-être l'occasion
de ferraille
par exemple dans d'autres pays donc là
l'afrique on du côté de l'asie
il existe des communauté rastafari
également en asie
oui alors il y en a un petit peu partout
hein après c'est un petit peu dur a
recensé on m'a déjà demandé la question
on a du mal à poser la question combien
il y a de rester ici ou ici c'est un
petit peu dur de pouvoir juger la fois
des gens donc donc c'est je peux pas
vous dire exactement après il ya quand
même une une institution organisée comme
lead belly f l'éthiopienne world fait
les reichel où il y aura il ya des
locales un petit peu partout dans le
monde
donc là on peut voir qu'il ya vraiment
une institution légale mais
mais il ya des rastas partout dans le
monde et puis c'est une philosophie de
vie donc après après il ya plein
d'autres
d'autres idéologies qui s'en rapproche
si on veut découvrir ce documentaire en
savoir un petit peu plus pour simplement
alors comme je le disais tout à l'heure
le but n'était pas de faire du
prosélytisme de dire soyez rasta ou pas
le but était de comprendre un petit peu
cette philosophie de vie de comprendre
les gens qui nous entourent on connaît
tous des rastas mais allez un petit peu
plus loin que l'apparence pour pour
savoir ce qu'elle pense comment elle
vivait et surtout quelle est leur
philosophie de vie est-ce qu'on peut par
exemple découvrir à travers le dvd ou
même une projection je sais pas
peut-être faire oui alors là mon travail
en ce moment consiste à chercher des
diffusions donc j'essaye de le diffuser
un petit peu partout surtout en france
mais aussi ailleurs et donc là je suis
très contente aussi d'être dans les dom
tom et donc on peut suivre la page
facebook déjà où il y aura toute
l'actualité des projections il ya un dvd
qui en vente sur le site internet
et c'est ça qui me plaît c'est que
justement les gens à la suite du film
vient souvent me voir en me disant je
savais pas tout ça j'ai appris beaucoup
de choses et ils se sentent et
s'identifie vraiment mouvement et c'est
ça que j'avais envie de montrer c'est
pas que tout le monde devienne rasta le
l'idée c'est plutôt que les gens cassent
ces clichés et j'inspire d'une vie plus
saine mais meyer est ce que
c'est parti à réaliser un documentaire à
s'intéresser maintenant au travail de
réalisateur sa cession des fonds propres
quand on parle réaliser ce type de
documentaire on prend sa caméra on pas
on paye son billet d'avion c'est ben oui
dans mon cas après moi c'est donc c'est
mon premier film
moi j'étais déjà un petit peu dans
l'audiovisuel mais j'ai dû aussi à
prendre donc à faire des prises de vue
même le montage les faits en grande
partie donc oui c'est un film qui a été
fait en grande partie est autoproduit
donc gelé autofinancé
c'est pas comme ça normalement que ça se
passe voilà dans la loire les fonds
avant tu vois la cerise et ensuite on
pas mais l'idée c'était aussi que
c'était une recherche personnelle donc
je voulais faire ce voyage et décider
des pays où je voulais aller
décider de qui je voulais interviewé
donc donc là j'étais coup vraiment
libres de le faire par moi-même
après c'est sûr que c'est difficile
maintenant de trouver les diffuseurs
voilà je suis pas j'ai pas vraiment dans
le parcours logique mais je suis très
contente d'être arrivée jusque ici et de
pouvoir le montrer et pouvoir avoir
cette interaction avec le public c'est
rencontre avec des rastas d'afrique de
la caraïbe ça vous en rapporter quoi
julie alors moi énormément parce que
au-delà de ce que vous pouvez voir dans
le film
moi j'ai après encore plus ans dans ses
recherches et est en fait pour moi c'est
vraiment un exemple un modèle comme on
disait voilà c'est je pense qu'on est
tous en recherche de vie meilleure à
tous les niveaux donc je parlais aussi
de l'identité la recherche d'identité
la société de consommation il ya
énormément de choses qui nous oppresse
des choses
voilà on est tous dans une recherche
personnelle de bonheur d'épanouissement
et là il ya quelques exemples pour pour
essayer de vivre mieux
donc si je peux si on peut tous prendre
exemple c'est ce sera ce serait que
mieux
dans le pire des cas ça peut être des
petites pistes dans lequel on peut
puiser se dire ah bah tiens ça c'est pas
mal intéressante cette piste-là on peut
peut-être faire ça à exploiter ou mettre
ça en pratique dans sa vie pour pouvoir
changer un petit peu à la façon de faire
les choses et vivre un petit peu plus
sereinement plus on a en harmonie avec
avec la nature avec nous mêmes et puis
arrêtez de juger les gens par
l'apparence et essayer de savoir un
petit peu plus de quoi on parle
réellement arrêter de juger les gens sur
l'apparence bob marley y aura beaucoup
fait pour pour changer enfin pourront en
tout cas véhiculer l'image des rastas
dans le monde
c'est vrai qu'il aura beaucoup fait les
groupes qui ont suivi également après on
a tendance aussi des fois associés
les locks au mouvement rasta ce n'est
pas forcément lié
parce qu'on a des locks qu'on les rastas
voilà c'est pas parce qu'on a déjà parce
qu'on est rasta ensuite c'est le port
des locks et liés à la bible en fait
donc c'est le voeu de nature et à qu'il
faut parce que se raser la tête ni ce
coupé les cheveux pour pour se mettre à
part en fait de la société et donc la
plupart des rastas ont des locks après
c'est pas facile dans la vie de trouver
un travail de trouver un logement avec
des locks donc y en a certains qui les
coupe pour pouvoir vivre et survivre
mais après c'est aussi un style
maintenant c'est devenu un style au
scapulaire donc voilà c'est ça on
retrouve on voit énormément de
dreadlocks dans la rue ça veut pas dire
que ce sont des faits et des fois les
clichés viennent du fait qu'on voit
quelqu'un qui a des locks il fait
quelque chose et on associe en dit tout
ça c'était un rasta café ça longtemps
fait de cette personne et bientôt rasta
et on fait l'amalgamé et des frais on
confond un petit peu les rastas les noms
restent à simplement parce qu'on
assimile les loques ce mouvement rasta
donc faire peut-être aussi attention à
ça oui on ne peut pas juger à tort en
fait tout à fait et c'est moi je suis
content d'avoir fait ce travail en
allant vraiment chercher les adeptes du
mouvement qui vivent un mode de vie
rasta parce que il ya déjà beaucoup de
travail qui a été fait sur le mouvement
que ce soit des livres ou des films
et c'est souvent des artistes reggae qui
vont venir parler c'est pas forcément
les meilleures personnes interviewées
parce qu'ils sont dans dans la célébrité
et puis dans leur vie de voyages et pas
forcément dans une vie vraiment de
droiture scène comme les personnes que
je suis allé interviewer et on parle
souvent que de la jamaïque et alors que
le mouvement voilà et ans
en afrique il est très présent dans la
caraïbe mais aussi ailleurs et donc
donc oui c'est important de voir que
c'est vraiment un mode de vie et que
c'est pas les dreadlocks qui font qu'ils
font le reste
en tout cas vous n'aurez donné envie
d'en découvrir d'en savoir un petit peu
plus sur le mouvement à cette avarie à
travers ce documentaire
il s'appelle iam a hissé sa disponible
sur facebook vous le disiez kahlan alors
oui pour pour pouvoir avoir des
informations via la page facebook qui
est à iéna et le film et il ya aussi le
site internet
ayhan a eu le film point moselle au
point fr en espérant le voir très
bientôt merci en tout cas julie amitié
est venu nous parler de votre travail
et puis également de ce superbe film à
voir donc à yantai merci nous avoir
suivis que vous soyez rasta ou pas je
vous souhaite un bon appétit à l'écouté
de la première on se retrouve très
bientôt
[Musique]